so the number one cause
of divorce into in america today the
number one thing that couples fight
about
money fights and money problems so
when your marriage is facing financial
stress
it is facing one of the most formidable
enemies of your marriage it will ever
face
more people split up over that than
anything else bankruptcy and divorce are
best buddies they hang out together
all the stats tell us that in 25 years
of financial coaching tells me that
and having lived through it myself i
mean sharon and i didn't get a divorce
but
we we you know the only reason we held
on to each other is get a better grip so
we could smack each other again
um that's a metaphor but um
so but i mean you know it's just man
when we were going broke we were like
claws were out teeth were were bared
you know it was like rough
she told me she said i'd leave but i
don't even have the money to do that
uh it's a long time ago i'll tell you
what it's still fresh in my mind i still
feel it in my spirit when i talk to
someone like that last caller who was
struggling
so let me just tell you it is normal
if you are struggling financially ladies
listen to me carefully
your man is struggling with his
self-esteem more than any time in his
life
i don't care what his age is i don't
care what his education level is
i don't care what his income used to be
or even what it is today
if you guys are in a financial pinch
it makes him feel bad about himself
period if he's self-employed
even more so
because then it's completely up to him
on his job
and it's not the job's not doing it the
business isn't doing it
and it just it i remember i mean it
smacks you
in the face and guys
feel worse about themselves at that
point ladies than ever before
so the last thing he needs in the middle
of something like that ladies is a
barking chihuahua around his ankles
it's the last thing he needs right then
guys listen to me
if you're married and you're struggling
financially
your lady is afraid in a place you don't
even have
she has a security gland that you don't
have and her security gland is spasming
she's afraid and
you know if you're struggling
financially
she needs an extra three to six
non-sexual hugs
a day some of you men need to look up
non-sexual
hug for the purpose of reassurance
that's leading nowhere
help you with that physical touch for
the purpose of reassurance that is going
nowhere
this is how you get through this stuff
guys
this is what you really do
and you hold hands and you grit your
teeth
and you resist the temptation ladies to
tear him down
and men you resist the temptation to
throw
fire on her fear
because when you start singing the hee
haw song you put her in intensive care
gloom despair and agony on me
when you start that crap men your lady
goes
she melts down in a place you don't even
have she's scared
and it's not because she's weaker she's
actually probably stronger
she's probably more resilient than you
are men in this case but she is afraid
in a place you don't have
because women are the main thing they
draw from money is security
men the main thing they draw from money
is esteem
we shouldn't we ought to draw it from
the lord we know that
but we're human and it's our broken
parts that do that it's
that's how it is no way around it
so make sure
men that you know this about your wives
ladies that you know this about your
husbands and you can get through hard
financial times and it not cost you your
marriage
as a matter of fact if you'll understand
these things and just talk about them
out loud
and you play all your cards face up a
little bit yeah i feel like crap right
now
yeah i'm really scared right now it's
okay to talk about
it and then you sit down go okay let's
do something about it well let's get rid
of this stupid car
and don't go looking at him and go you
know you're such an idiot when you
bought these cars he already feels like
an idiot he doesn't need you to tell him
that
if we don't sell these cars it's all
gonna go down the toilet she doesn't
need you to say that she already knows
that she's already afraid don't throw
fire on the gas a gas on the fire okay
take the action steps without turning
them into blame
you don't have to throw anybody under
the bus to sell the bus
sell it sell so much stuff the kids are
hiding they think they're next
get six extra jobs sit down get on a
dadgum budget
listen i don't care who can't get a date
turn off your television
average millionaire can't tell you who
got thrown off the island
turn off your stupid television
most this stuff's not worth work
watching anyway
like none of it hardly so you know
concentrate on something that matters
which is your life
getting your life back sit down start
making lists of things we need to sell
let's make craigslist happy
light up ebay baby let's get some things
going here
let's take some action steps here's the
weirdest thing
i'm so worried i've heard that like
i don't know 25 000 times in 20 years
doing financial coaching
i'm so worried i've been there where i
said i'm so worried i've been there
i remember saying that you know weirdest
thing about worry
if you work all the time you ain't got
time to worry
if you have a game plan where you're
aiming at something the worry just
starts to dissipate
because most of your worry is about
something that isn't even going to
happen
anyway but if you'll go about go about
your business of busting into it
moving your life around taking an impact
on your life instead of sitting around
waiting on it to happen to you
it changes everything it suddenly
changes your self-esteem men and ladies
it suddenly helps your fear go away
when you get in a game plan and you go
after it
and you you you just draw back and start
punching stuff
not each other it changes everything you
guys
it moves the needle it's the funniest
thing your self-esteem will get better
when you start doing something about
your situation
your fear will go down when you start
doing something about your situation
when you go to work and you lay out a
plan but if you try to hide
watching die hard 16 rocky 46
again on the television one more version
of these things
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again
you can try to hide in hbo but sooner or
later they're going to cut it off
if you don't pay the bill
so you got to get you got to get in the
zone here action
and activity focus with a game plan
that the two of you are unified on
suddenly the fear starts to back off
suddenly your self-esteem starts to
improve and you can be
so deep in a hole that you can't even
see daylight and your self-esteem will
be just fine because you got a plan
and you're working a plan you can be so
deep in a hole you can't see daylight
and instead of being terrified by that
you will be optimistic because you have
a plan and you're working the plan with
great
focused intensity and energy and you're
doing it together
unified i've watched couples
that i didn't think were going to make
it completely turn their marriage around
just because of those things right there
they understood the demons that they
were facing
and they understood they had to take
action and they had to do it together
and they had to do it along a focused
plan and when they do that
you save not only your financial
situation but your marriage and the
process
oh and by the way there's little people
in your house that are watching
they're watching how you handle life's
crap
you're gonna get a buried bite or you're
gonna get a shovel let's get to work
people
there's stuff to do here there's no
reason for you to surrender
you do not need to surrender you can win
don't let this financial stuff
take your marriage it will take your
marriage if you let it
but you're not a victim you decide
you get the dignity of deciding whether
you're going to win or not
and i'll help you this is the dave
ramsey show
you